pour en parler nous sommes avec arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire bonsoir à vos
côtés rachid digoit président du
collectif inter bloc
bonsoir est également toujours avec nous
alexis poulain éditorialistes alors
rachid digoin on sait que la situation
dans les hôpitaux est très compliqué est
ce que vous avez senti avec ces annonces
qui emmanuel macron avait pris les
mesures des difficultés auxquelles vous
êtes confrontés aujourd'hui
écoutez ce soir il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
de mots pour pour l'hôpital
c'est ce qu'on peut dire ce soir
notamment il dit qu'on a tiré des leçons
de la première vague ce qui est
totalement faux puisque s'il avait tiré
les leçons
on aurait ouvert des places de
réanimation supplémentaires on n'en
serait pas à toujours 5000 lits
actuellement et surtout il aurait
recruté du personnel et surtout aussi le
ségur n'aura pas accouché d'une souris
puisque les ramones récent sanaria ne
sont pas à la hauteur donc comment
aujourd'hui en pet attractif au niveau
de l'hôpital ça c'est la grosse question
c'est vrai la renommée l'invité assez
peu de mots finalement ce soir pour
l'hôpital c'était quoi à l'intention du
président s'étaient de rassurer les
français
elle c'était de remettre de la clarté
dans le cap du gouvernement ce soir
comment vous l'avez compris c'était
surtout le résultat d'une communication
politique qui est extrêmement
contradictoires et qui était inaudible
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
si aujourd'hui on remonte au cran
supplémentaire des institutions c'est à
dire le président de la république c'est
que les étages intermédiaires n'ont pas
été capables sur le fond d'expliquer est
la politique qui est menée dans ce pays
pour contenir et gérer l'épidémie
je ne suis pas du tout sûr que le
président de la république ce soir est
convaincu les françaises et les français
des mesures qu'il a pu annoncer ce sont
des mesures qui malheureusement
traduisent vraisemblablement aux yeux
d'un grand nombre de compatriotes de nos
compatriotes par dont l'absence
finalement de réaction des pouvoirs
publics durant les mois qui ont
suivi le déconfinement enfin quand on
peut prendre une mesure comme celle du
corps ce qui va toucher quand il le
rappeler 20 millions de français c'est
une mesure extrêmement contraignante
bien évidemment au niveau des libertés
publiques et des libertés privées de
chacun d'entre nous mais c'est une
mesure en outre ti sur le plan
économique que pour un certain nombre de
secteurs va peser extrêmement l'eau donc
la communication qui était la
communication du président de la
république et télécommunications un peu
bon docteur de fanni ou joueurs de
bonneteau qui essayent finalement de
faire passer des mesures qui sont quand
même très contraignante à la fois encore
une fois sur le plan de notre vie
quotidienne mais également sur le plan
économique et une communication qui a du
mal sur le fond à cacher ou à effacer un
certain nombre de questions que des
professionnels de santé se pose mais
aussi que de larges segments de
l'opinion publique se posent en matière
finalement de gestion de cette épidémie
depuis la sortie du déconfinement alors
vous lisiez une décision ne tient pas
que directement les commerces qui
devront fermer leurs portes à partir de
21h on écoute ce qu'a dit à ce propos le
chef de l'état tous les cinémas tous les
théâtres tous les restaurants tous les
bars vers le ride
tout le monde est chez soi ou sur le
chemin du retour vers chez soi alors les
ils fermeront en effet pour cet ordre
après ça dépend ouf
je pense qu'il faut accompagner de
beaucoup de bon sens tout cela est d'une
gestion très local c'est à dire que
évidemment tous tous ces établissements
se devront fermer à 21h13 situation
particulière si vous habitez à côté du
restaurant vous pouvez sortir à 21h être
chez vous si vous avez une demi heure de
transport vous allez vous organiser pour
le quitter à 20h30
et puis après il y aura aussi des
éléments de concertation locale parce
qu'on voit bien que les situations sont
très différentes
l'organisation de nos vies ne sont pas
les mêmes à grenoble rouen saint-etienne
ou paris avec ses poulains avaient
fédération dénonce il y à quelques
instants une fermeture déguisée
et de l'hôtellerie restauration c'est le
cas selon vous oui c'est un secteur
sacrifier comme beaucoup d'autres fins
tous les secteurs à peu près du
divertissement du vivre ensemble tous
les secteurs qui accueille la vie sont
sacrifiés parce qu'il faut travailler
le couvre-feu vous savez aucun pouvoir
n'a lutter contre un virus avec un
couvre feu
à quoi ça sert vous l'avez montré dans
le sujet ça sert simplement à lutter
contre la révolte sociale
donc ce que fait le pouvoir aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il prévoit la révolte sociale
qui va venir en 2021 quand les aides
vont être asséchés quand le chômage
partiel va s'arrêter et quand les
faillites sont trop nombreuses pour que
on ne pourra pour que le pouvoir ne
puisse plus caché en fait l'impéritie
dans cette gestion de crise ducobu qui
est devenue une crise sociale et
économique
ce soir emmanuel macron n'a à aucun
moment rappelé les chiffres réels de
cette épidémie
que ce soit le taux de mortalité que ce
soit le nombre de personnes aujourd'hui
en réanimation que ce soit la réalité
des urgences à part le fait de dire
qu'il n'ya pas assez dit ça c'est son
fait c'est le fait aussi de jean castex
lorsqu'il était secrétaire général
adjoint de l'elysée c'est le fait de
cette caste qui s'est approprié l'état
et qui ne contrôle plus rien alors
peut-être qu'il serait temps que les
citoyens français et bien reprennent le
contrôle de la démocratie et de l'outil
républicain parce que ce qu'il se passe
ce soir c'est n'importe quoi c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui me dépasse et
qui dépasse beaucoup d'entre nous je
pense qu'on est tous les téléspectateurs
étaient sidérés en entendant cette
histoire de couvre-feu parce qu'encore
une fois qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que de 6h à 21h le virus
finalement ne peut pas vous attendre
parce que vous travaillez
mais que de 21h à 6h et bien comme vous
êtes chez vous il ne vous entendra pas
l'histoire de rentrer dans la vie privée
des gens de dire que vous ne pouvez pas
recevoir plus de six personnes c'est du
jamais vu
enfin qui sort ce chiffre de 6 comme
halladay a rappelé mme ou le confinement
on avait sorti le chiffre de 100 km on
ne pouvait pas dépasser les 100 km
autour de son domicile
tout ça c'est orwell tout ça c'est de la
science fiction on est en train de vivre
une dystopie autoritaire pour ne pas
dire totalitaire qui est en train de
nous faire perdre pied avec la
démocratie et avec le bon sens parce qu
emmanuel macron ce soir nous dit tout
cela avec un petit sourire narquois
en parlant de bon sens en parlant des
forts en d'efforts communs en parlant du
fait qu'il a besoin de tout le monde
pour mettre en place ces mesures qui
n'ont aucun sens
si on veut lutter contre le virus on ne
sait pas ça tout simplement arnaud
bénédicte si vous avez le sentiment vous
aussi d'être dans une science fiction
aujourd'hui comme le souligne alexis
poulain on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle pour des circonstances
qui ne devrait pas l'être
fondamentalement vous avez rappelé dans
votre reportage d'utilisation de du
couvre feu
l'utilisation du couvre-feu sur le plan
historique
il répond à des situations de trouble à
l'ordre public qui sont des situations
de violence des situations
conflictuelles
là en l'occurrence on est dans une
situation où nous devons de fait en
effet lutter contre un virus mais en
effet les clips les mesures qui sont
prises ce soir sont des mesures qui pose
fondamentalement question pour tous ceux
qui sont attachés au respect des
principes de la démocratie libérale je
rappelle que la liberté de circulation
et elle a été un principe fondateur de
nos résine que la liberté de recevoir
des genres c'est soit c'est à dire
d'avoir une vie plus lisez est un
principe fondateur et le problème fils
pause et vraisemblablement ce qui va
être retenu par une partie non
négligeable de l'opinion publique qu'ils
jugent déjà sévèrement la façon dont
l'exécutif a géré cette crise depuis le
début c'est que la société est devenue
la barrière d'ajustement des impérities
de l'état en l'occurrence parce que tout
simplement nous n'avons pas été en
mesure de prendre les dispositions qui
sur le plan sanitaire aurait pu
permettre vraisemblablement d'éviter
d'en venir à ce type de mesures
c'est la société que l'on va contraindre
encore plus mais par contre avec un
petit disons un petit détail qui est
qu'à son importance c'est que la société
doit continuer à travailler c'est à dire
que les françaises et les français ou
les franciliens vont pouvoir prendre
sans problème les transports en commun
aux heures de pointe mais par contre ne
pourront pas recevoir chez eux et
éventuellement plus de six personnes
d'ailleurs j'attends de voir les bases
légales et les bases juridiques sur
lesquels d'ailleurs ne s'est pas
aventuré le président de la république
iq pour tout simplement poser ce type de
pratique de ce type de mesures en
l'occurrence on est disons face à un
état qui aujourd'hui n'est pas en mesure
d'assurer vraisemblablement la première
mission qui est la sienne c'est la
protection des citoyens et des
citoyennes face à une pandémie dont
personne ne nie en effet la réalité mais
en l'occurrence on avait trois mois
encore le mois de mai et le mois de
septembre pour s'organiser pour éviter
que l'on revienne à une situation
finalement de confinement nocturne de la
population des grandes métropoles je
rappelle encore une fois 20 millions de
françaises et de français
richard des voix effectivement le
président de la république ce soir-là
dis clairement on n'a pas le dic h et
donc on ne va pas pouvoir non plus faire
appel à d'autres régions pour accueillir
des patients malades on aurait eu le
temps en trois mois effectivement de
repenser l'organisation de l'hôpital
selon vous injecter plus de moyens en
trois mois ça aurait été suffisant
trois mois nettement ça aurait pas été
suffisant puisque ça fait des années
qu'on subit la casse de l'hôpital dont
ça aurait été très largement compliqué
après je voulais revient sur le discours
de monsieur macron c'est vrai que il
insiste enfin on dirait que c'est sur la
sphère privée en fait qu'on se
contaminer ça me fait un peu râpé un
discours qu'on a qu'on a sans cesse sur
sur les hôpitaux par l'équipe d'hygiène
qui nous disent que finalement c'est
pendant nos temps de pause qu'on se
contaminent alors que on est on est on
est finalement exposé au virus et on
prend en charge des patients qu'aux vide
là on ne se contaminent jamais et
finalement c'est pendant nos temps de
pause quand se contamine aussi vous
voulez c'est un peu nous nous jeter la
pierre et et met face à nos
responsabilités alors que finalement
comme dit comme dit tout à l'heure dans
les transports ça pose pas de problème
au travail ça pose pas de problème et
c'est alors rachidi loi demain vous
allez battre le pavé à une manifestation
des soignants est prévu pour demander
plus de moyens humains et financiers
davantage de liens d'hôpitaux on va
regarder tout de suite à ce sujet un
reportage de david tait l'ifa et de
l'est
sauf cinq mois après le pic de la crise
sanitaire les revendications demeurent
les mêmes pour les personnels
hospitaliers de l'hexagone et le ségur
de la santé n'a fait au mieux qu attiser
la colère dans leurs rangs de la
frustration
c'est ce qui devrait ressortir des
revendications affichées ce jeudi pour
la plupart des métiers du secteur
hospitalier
rien n'a changé depuis cet été on est
solidaires car c'est pire qu'avant le
ségur de la santé non seulement les
promesses n'ont pas été tenues
non seulement le segura oublié plein de
gens dont nous mais en terme
d'organisation des soins on n'a pas tiré
les leçons de la première vague de co
vide
on n'a même pas été invité aux c'est dur
pourtant il ya beaucoup à dire sur les
cent vingt mille infirmières libérales
partis la fleur au fusil au printemps
pour prendre en charge les patients sans
masque sans protection
moins de trois mois se sont écoulés
depuis les conclusions du ségur de la
santé et rien ne semble se concrétiser
un constat amer qui semble partagé par
tous les secteurs de l'hôpital
cette grève du 15 octobre à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale doit avant tout
permettre de pointer le manque
d'effectif mais aussi des salaires
toujours peu élevés ou encore la
suppression de trois mille quatre cents
lits en 2019
on ne peut pas dire que la situation a
évolué tant à l'hôpital que dans les
établissements de l'action sociale
la première revendication des salariés
de ces différents secteurs était
d'obtenir plus de moyens humains
or malgré les belles paroles au début de
la crise et les promesses force est de
constater qu'il n'ya rien aucun
recrutement des moyens humains restent
les mêmes une colère également partagé
par les médecins de ville en cause des
tarifs bloqué depuis 2010 est qui font
l'objet de discussions avec l'assurance
maladie
les offres de revalorisation sont jugées
ridicules par les syndicats du côté du
gouvernement on réclame de la patience
tout ne se règle pas d'un coup de
baguette magique indique-t-on au cabinet
d'olivier ferrand mais les décisions
prises tarde à se concrétiser
à l'aube de la deuxième vague du coc vie
de 19 le personnel hospitalier espère
lui enfant obtenir des avancées
concrètes alors à redon benedetti dans
cette ambiance de tension intentions du
personnel soignant est ce que le
président est encore audible aujourd'hui
on va le voir très rapidement ce qui est
sûr c'est que en tout cas encore une
fois les étages intermédiaires qui mène
jusqu'aux présidents ont été totalement
inaudible ces dernières semaines avec on
l'a répété des messages parfaitement
contradictoire donc si le président est
obligé de monter en première ligne comme
il le fait ce soir c'est que il prend
acte de la faiblesse en tout cas de son
dispositif gouvernemental
donc ça c'est un premier élément le
deuxième élément c'est que moi ce qui me
paraît quand même extrêmement important
dans cette déclaration ce soir c'est que
il touche à des choses qui sont très
symboliques et on l'a dit
il est clair que la notion de couvre feu
fait appel quand même un imaginaire qui
politiquement est très fort ensuite il
ya un deuxième aspect c'est que cette
notion de couvre-feu si elles touchent
20 millions de françaises de france de
français elle entraîne le fait parce que
c'est la stratégie qui a été choisi par
le gouvernement c'est à dire une
stratégie de gestion différenciée de la
lutte contre l'épidémie
elle entraîne assentiment mais sans
vraiment d'inégalité entre les
françaises et les français donc cet
aspect là il va falloir aussi de voir le
gérer et du côté de l'exécutif
moi je suis pas du tout sûr que ce soit
encore une fois le président de la
république est fondamentalement rassurer
l'opinion publique
il a plutôt d'une certaine manière en
creux souligné les insuffisances de
notre système sanitaire pour faire face
à l'épidémie et les comparaisons qu'il
fait avec un certain nombre de nos
voisins européens
d'une certaine manière ne font que
confirmer que comparaison n'est pas
raison en l'occurrence parce que quand
même quand on voit la situation
aujourd'hui sur le plan épidémique que
c'est un certain nombre de leurs voisins
elle est quand même de deux manières en
tout cas j'allais dire qualitative mieux
maîtriser qu'en france donc il y a un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui
qui sait que la france se retrouve dans
une situation finalement où on a le
sentiment que le retour d'expérience qui
ont dû être fait suite à ce que nous
avons connues et était véritablement
clairement difficilement prévisible il
faut le dire au mois de mars n'a pas
fait l'objet d'une certaine manière de
mesures correctives qui aurait pu
vraisemblablement peut-être évité cette
contrainte qui va peser à la fois sur la
vie privée des françaises et des
français mais aussi sur la vie
économique et sociale parce que le vrai
sujet le deuxième front est en train
quand même aujourd'hui de se lever c'est
le front économique et social parce que
nous ne sont pas encore rentrés dans la
séquence où les conséquences
in fine et de la crise des conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
sanitaire ont fait disons valoir tous
leurs effets donc lié aussi cet aspect
là qu'il faut pas
justement alexis poulain ce soir le chef
de l'état a annoncé une aide aux plus
précaires qui subissent aussi plein de
plein fouet cette crise sanitaire aide
exceptionnelle de 150 euros avec 100
euros de plus par enfant pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa et des appels
pendant six semaines quel est votre
regard sur ces mesures est ce qu'elles
sont suffisantes est ce qu'elles vont
suffire pour ces gens à survivre pendant
cette crise finalement c'est une mesure
d'urgence et les bienvenus parce que les
pauvres sont les grands oubliés du plan
de relance seulement 0 8% qui est dédié
à la lutte contre l'extrême pauvreté et
la précarité mais une fois encore que
fait manuel macron il choisit l'option
de la prime exceptionnelle 150 euros et
100 euros par enfant
plutôt que de remonter les minima
sociaux qui dit-il est bien serait
dangereux parce que si on remonte à les
minima sociaux et bien il n'y aurait pas
de retour à l'emploi parce que ce serait
finalement vivre d'une rente que d'être
aidés parce qu'on rentre dans l'extrême
précarité
ce qui ce qui risque de se passer ce qui
est extrêmement grave et l' oms la
souligner c'est que le confinement en
fait est est une catastrophe pour les
plus précaires et les plus pauvres parce
que ce sont eux qui en souffrent le plus
de voir l'arrêt de l'activité ou l'arrêt
de secteurs entiers d'activité et rien
n'est fait pour éviter que des français
déjà au bord de la précarité ne sombre
dans l'extrême pauvreté
expulsion perte de logement pertes
d'emplois évidemment impossibilité de
payer les factures de l'énergie ou même
simplement de se nourrir
les banques alimentaires on veut
exploser le nombre de personnes qui
venaient aux banques alimentaires et 7
ce coût social du virus il n'est pas
pris en compte pas mal macron puisque
lui ne veut pas remonter les minima
sociaux
il ne veut pas revenir non plus sur les
sf il va falloir que les très riches
parce que l'écart se creuse bien aide la
société à se remettre de ce virus si on
veut vraiment faire quelque chose que ce
soit en payant des impôts qu'on évite
l'évasion fiscale l'optimisation fiscale
tout simplement parce qu'on a besoin de
services publics qui fonctionnent
l'hôpital la justice la police
l'éducation nationale tout ça doit être
financée par l'impôt et les plus riches
doivent payer à hauteur de ce qu'ils
peuvent payer et les plus pauvres doit
être aidé parce que la pauvreté si elle
est vraiment violente et si elle est
vécue comme elle pourra l'être l'an
prochain elle va coûter beaucoup plus
cher à la société que si en amont au
pouvait
voir les leviers de solidarité qui avait
été mis en place par l'assurance sociale
par la france d'après-guerre
donc aujourd'hui on a tout faux sur tous
les tableaux que ce soit sur la lutte
sanitaire manque de moyens que ce soit
sur la lutte contre la pauvreté manque
de moyens que ce soit pour la reprise
d'activité n'importe quoi le couvre-feu
ne va pas aider à la reprise d'activité
c'est que que 10 mm macro ce soir aux
français il dit ayez peur mais pas trop
quand vous avez peur vous ne consommez
pas quand vous avez peur vous ne faites
pas que l'activité reprend donc là on
est en train de perdre un pays en direct
avec des techno qui sont totalement
perdus parce qu'ils ne sont pas à la
taille de la tâche tout simplement merci
à tous les trois d'avoir répondu à nos
questions décrypter ce discours du chef
de l'état
ce soir qui a annoncé je vous le rappel
de nouvelles mesures merci à avoir nos
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire
merci à vous rachid digoit président du
collectif inter-blogues merci également
à vous alexis poulain éditorialistes